mme ans mais quarante ans plus tard la
donne a changé
robert léger une pensée pour les groupes
qui ont suivi beau dommage quand on
vendait un peu d'albums abbey avait des
choux qui à l'entrée est on est on
survivait h lâcher de sa main ce qui est
plus le cas maintenant
l'industrie musicale mais effectivement
plus la même
il se vend de moins en moins dix le
nombre d'albums vendus annuellement au
québec a décliné de 77% par rapport à
son sommet de 2004 l'année où les
cowboys fringants on en dise qu'ils leur
succès les étoiles filantes
je susi
mais non
aujourd'hui on prend un album pour comme
une carte de visite pour aller faire des
spectacles parce que finalement pour
qu'un groupe survivent au québec c'est
les concerts qui permettent ça
le 4 octobre les cowboys fringants
lançaient leur nouvel album est adulé
que j'achète encore de serre est
d'ailleurs gelé sur moi c'est le
consommateur quel choix en fin de compte
donc moi je dise quoi les plateformes de
streaming
je viens voir les spectacles j'achète
des billets malgré ces quelques
irréductibles les nouvelles chansons des
cowboys fringants ces coûteront surtout
sur internet
le groupe se désole du fait que les
revenus tirés des écoutes en ligne sont
minimes
environ 5000 $ pour 1 million d' écoute
et ses deux ans de travail qui peuvent
valoriser à travers ça c'est pas la
faute de personne mais on doit
collectivement et réfléchie pour qu'il
ya une santé dans la culture il ya une
situation qui change c'est vrai dans le
domaine du transport on devient avec le
taxi au québec c'est c'est dans toutes
les industries que c'est comme ça puisse
pour se construire à les pouvoirs
publics en zambie
penchez-vous des fois sur des règles des
normes des lois qui sont un petit peu
archaïque
en pleine campagne électorale des
dizaines de musiciens interpelle les
politiciens et leur demande d'agir pour
protéger la musique québécoise
il faut convaincre et évidemment
patrimoine canadien les ministères la
culture mais aussi le crtc je pense
qu'ils sont en mesure d'adopter des
règlements pour faire en sorte que les
fournisseurs d'accès internet soit
contraint à verser une partie de leurs
profits dans un fonds 10 ans puis que ce
fonds le servent à la production de
contenus
il propose que ce fonds soit également
alimentée par un montant prélevé lors de
l'achat d'appareils numériques comme ça
se fait avec les cd vierges
à deux semaines du gala de l'adisq sa
vice présidente lance un cri du coeur
il est plus que temps y est même n'est
pas trop tard parce que c'est il faut
pas parce que la création est toujours
là il faut trouver des axes évidemment
cette création l'homme et les militants
robert léger garde de bons souvenirs de
l'époque du 67-65 vallier montréal mais
il souhaite surtout que des beau dommage
il y en ait d'autres
je vais pas certain qu'on aurait survécu
sur tout un groupe
vous pouviez qu'un groupe libre maigres
revenus il faut les séparer à cinq ou
six ce qui fait qu'on aurait peut-être
malheureusement abandonné
[Musique]
et si nabi alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal il ça aurait été une
perte pour nous s'il avait abandonné
alors nabi vous avez parle aux
différents partis se sont engagés jeudi
soir des rangs des termes assez généraux
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire mais
tout le monde le reconnaît qu'un
problème pas triste du côté des libéraux
on souligne que janet yelle a été
mandaté pour déposer un rapport sur la
question que dans la première année d'un
nouveau gouvernement libéral y aurait un
projet de loi qui serait adoptée
du côté des conservateurs